[Music]
clark county students start school on
monday
that means kids will be waking up early
and after a summer off we need to wake
up our brains here to help us with our
brain health is cat hartley the project
manager at cleveland clinic lou rovo
center for brain health it's great to
have you on the show it's a pleasure to
be here thank you so much for having us
how important is it to exercise our
brains wow well our brains really are
the control command center right for all
we retain
remember
and we need to keep it healthy
and you have they're kind of like six
tips or certain exercises that we can do
to improve our brain health and memory
what are those things that we can do i
think this is great for students and
parents by the way absolutely everyone
as a community influencer yes it's great
to spread this information so the
cleveland clinic has identified six
pillars of brain health that includes
exercise nutrition
you know continuing to learn no matter
how old you are
let's break it down so we're talking
about we're talking about exercise and
students they go to school on monday but
that's why recess is important is it not
yeah get out and play just put it all
behind you because when we pump that
heart up we get oxygen and the nutrients
to our brain that it needs to perform
well and i think that's the same for
adults if you're in an office for four
or five hours and you're working in
front of your computer all day you need
to step outside and just get some fresh
air yeah stand up more we need to get
that
oxygen and like the nutrients
really to energize our brains and how
important is is the lunch that the
students if they're packing or buying it
at the school how important is lunch you
are what you eat
yes and that's your fuel right for your
brain and it can either make you sleepy
and tired with poor choices or ones from
the mediterranean diet much better
choices so like salads and what would be
the best thing what would you think
would be the best ideal lunch for our
first time a little more fruits and
vegetables yeah that salad with a little
bit of turkey maybe some
nuts
vegetables
those are much better options you know
our fast foods students are watching
right now and parents and they're
getting ready for school on monday and
probably been staying up late also it's
summertime and friday night saturday
stay up how important is that good
night's sleep come sunday night before
school starts a lot of students right
now have been on new zealand time zone
right
it is time to get your body back in
rhythm and one of the best things to do
is to go to bed at the same time wake up
at the same time every day
that's great on that schedule it helps
your body i love it really perform and
those electronics at night you have to
just you got to put them down and go to
sleep at least an hour before oh it's
good that's great
cat we appreciate it so much we'll have
all the information up on our website
thank you so much for joining us you and
i hope you maximize your brain
absolutely i'm gonna start doing all
that stuff right now all right rocky
i'll send it over to you